Oh Oh No Oh what have we done
if only we had listened to Nancy Pelosi
they're all dead they're all dead
because of a relatively modest tax
reform package that slightly lowers
rates but doesn't even consolidate the
brackets they're all dead oh why didn't
we listen we will discuss the reaction
to tax reform passing then the great
Matt Walsh Paul Cardinal blah and Jacob
Arry joined a panel of deplorable x' to
discuss Nikki Haley's tough talk at the
UN and Trump's threats the mother who is
only two months older than her daughter
the catholic sex abuse scandal 15 years
later and most importantly we debate
hashtag never Santa conservatives who
deny the war on Christmas I'm Michael
Knowles and this is the Michael Nolt
show
[Music]
Republicans have finally passed tax
reform let's just take a live look at
the House floor
[Music]
oh no it's gonna topple them
Wow that is even worse than I thought it
was that comet just striking the earth
tidal waves everywhere really really bad
it gets ugly in Washington but that's
really bad
so the apocalypse has happened it's all
over we're all dead I guess but you're
still alive I don't know maybe it was
like the rapture all the good people
went up to heaven and it's just you and
me we're the ones that were left
so before tax reform the Washington Post
in the wonk blog said quote Senate tax
bill would cut taxes of wealthy and
increase taxes on families earning less
than $75,000 by 2027
if the tax cuts don't repealed then guys
go go back up again but by just $75,000
it's gonna raise the taxes now after tax
reform the Washington Post got a little
bit more honest they said quote the tax
bill is likely to become more popular
after passage but here's the truth it
says 8 in 10 Americans will pay lower
taxes next year according to the
nonpartisan Tax Policy centers analysis
of the final bill only 5% of people will
pay more next year
that's me mostly mostly those are folks
who earn six figures and own expensive
houses in places with high local taxes
such as New York and California really
and they forgot to include people who
wrote a blank book one time yeah that
we're also lumped in there forget owning
a home or anything so that that was the
Armageddon everything that's going to be
awful the taxes are gonna go up on
everybody until it happens then they say
oh well never mind I guess actually all
of you are going to get a tax cut whoops
I guess we got it wrong a day ago and
for the last three months
in other news AT&T just announced that
it will pay quote a special $1,000 bonus
to more than 200,000 AT&T US employees
due to the tax reform passage it will
also increase u.s. capital spending by 1
billion dollars billion with a B Boeing
not to be out shown just announced 300
million dollars in employee related and
charitable investments to spur
innovation and growth in response to the
tax reform so it sounds pretty good to
me I don't know I'm no expert on tax law
or the economy but it sounds ok
nevertheless Democrats persisted Rosie
O'Donnell wrote in all caps of course no
no I will not kill Americans for the
super-rich I what
kill them because slightly lower taxes
kills people as she also offered to pay
two million dollars to the Senators to
vote against the tax bill which is a
felony it's a federal crime
but it's okay out a been tweeted and
said to lock her up not a bad idea it
this is even as this is happening so
that it's going to be all they know it's
going to happen I can't imagine that
they're so stupid and ignorant as to
think that taxes are going to kill
people but if then again I'm we're
talking about lefty Democrats in
Hollywood in DC not to be outdone by
Rosie O'Donnell Nancy Pelosi one upped
her this GOP tax game cent is simply
theft monumental brazen theft from the
American middle class and from every
person who aspires to reach it
the GOP tax game is not a vote for an
investment in growth or jobs it is a
vote to install a permanent plutocracy
in our nation they'll be cheering that
later it does violence to the vision of
our founders it disrespects the
sacrifice of our men and women in
uniform who are a large part of our
middle class and to whom we owe a future
worthy of their sacrifice anything else
is there anything else Nancy in there
it's unbelievable so according to Nancy
Pelosi letting people keep a little bit
more of their money as theft and taking
more of their money as charity that's
how it works in Nancy Pelosi is mind she
says that it is betrays the founders
that betrays the founding vision of the
founding fathers just a little history
lesson for Nancy Pelosi the first
federal income tax was enacted in 1861
all of the founders were dead long dead
by that time the first corporate tax was
instituted in 1894 but that was ruled
unconstitutional by the Supreme Court
nevertheless it was reinitiated in 1909
and if my math works the founding
fathers who lived in the 18th century
were no longer alive they never had that
vision they had no vision for a personal
federal income tax or for a federal
corporate tax she then Nancy Pelosi
can't help but use veterans as a
political prop here men and women in
uniform
I have no
idea why there it has no relation
whatsoever to this tax reform bill but
Nancy Pelosi has never been beholden to
the fact and don't worry it gets even
better at this news conference and on
the floor you Democrats talk about this
bill often in very apocalyptic terms but
isn't really what's going on is that
many people are getting a very modest
tax cut and some people are getting a
tax increase while a lot of this is also
going to business but it's not the end
of the world no it is the end of this
healthcare the debate on health care is
life death this is Armageddon this is a
very big deal because you know why
there's really a very hard way to come
back from this they take us further more
deeply into debt what can you do but
raise taxes they contend that they're a
gift to corporate America but trillion
and a half dollars could be up to a
trillion half dollars will be paid for
by the growth that creates and even
their own people say nonsense not true
it is Armageddon
no no hey wait hold on it is Armageddon
and obviously this rhetoric is insane so
she's saying that it's a gift to
corporate America isn't a gift to
corporate America it lets them keep more
of the money that they've earned if
that's not a gift and maybe a Nancy
Pelosi's mind it is but that isn't a
gift and then she says but it'll be it's
it's so hard to undo that's why her
argument is it's Armageddon because it's
so hard to undo this in order to undo
this Democrats will have to raise taxes
you know the thing that Democrats have
always done since the beginning of time
since the first sunrise on earth yeah
that they'll have to do that it's very
hard how how would Democrats ever raise
taxes I can't I can't imagine now I'm a
little confused Democrats say that
slightly lower tax rates will literally
murder people
I betrays the founding fathers and would
result in Armageddon that seems to me
like pretty reckless rhetoric doesn't it
that seems a little bit like reckless
rhetoric to me but I thought it was
Trump who used all of that reckless
rhetoric which is typical of the
rhetoric the reckless rhetoric you're
hearing from the candidates especially
on the GOP side I am
prepared to ready to actually take on
those challenges not engage in a lot of
you know irresponsible reckless rhetoric
Senator McConnell and all congressional
Republicans leaders have never taken a
stand against Trump's while rhetoric
Hillary was saying Donald Trump has to
stop the rhetoric he has to stop it it's
and my people are great it's these
people that are the problem well said
well said yeah his rhetoric is just fine
compared to those guys they're the ones
they're constantly talking about all the
rhetoric oh the rhetoric that rhetoric
listen to the way they talk listen to
what you just heard from him and then
don't forget the Democrats of the party
that told you if you like your doctor
you can keep your doctor
Obamacare wouldn't raise taxes or
premiums only later to admit well you
didn't think you they'd get all that
great stuff for free did you the party
who told you I did not have sexual
relations with that woman the party have
told you the terrorist attack in
Benghazi which they knew for certain to
be a terror attack was really caused by
a random YouTube video than they
imprisoned the guy for it the party who
told you Trump could never win that said
that none of Hillary's emails were
marked as classified that said Hillary
had turned over all of her work-related
emails they told you Hillary had never
been subpoenaed with regard to her email
that told you Barack Obama had no
knowledge of Hillary's private email
server the party that told you Romney
hadn't paid his income taxes the party
that told you that net neutrality will
end the Internet as we know it oh god is
he is did a feed cut out did that
because the Internet as we know it is
over so I presume
oh no it's exactly the same as it always
was now those are just a smattering of
the minor lies completely untrue but
some of these lies stick for instance I
bet if you went out on the street and
asked anybody were there any weapons of
mass destruction discovered in Iraq they
tell you absolutely not Bush lied people
died but there were weapons of mass
destruction found in Iraq
the New York Times even admitted that
there were in 2014 we found a ton of
chemical weapons we found them as early
as 2004 but we didn't tout it because we
were afraid that terrorists we're gonna
go find them and use them so total lie
we're told by Hollywood by the left that
JFK was murdered by a right-wing
conspiracy in Texas so that movie JFK's
about by Oliver Stone that isn't true
JFK was an anti-communist he was killed
by a communist he we know that he did it
we know that he had connections to the
Soviet Union and to
Cuba and to Mexico if you met with
Cubans in Mexico nevertheless they
create this total life you ask most
people on the street they would say oh
yes dark forces of hate in Texas they've
been spinning that yarns since the
moment he was assassinated we were told
by these people that the russians hacked
the election for donald trump there is
no evidence of this not no evidence at
all there is plenty of evidence that the
russians colluded with the democrats
there's no evidence that the russians
did legitimized our election to give
donald trump victory and they tell us
this one this one persists all the time
that the Democrat and the Republican
parties switched because the Democrat
Party is trash it is an awful awful
party it's the party of slavery it's the
party of cronyism it's the party of Jim
Crow it's the party of urban destruction
it's the party of stealing your wealth
and your freedom and then they decided
that one day one day magically and I
don't know like 1967 yeah let's say 67
we all just decided we all got together
and said okay you Republicans now you're
going to be Democrats and we Democrat
now we're gonna be Republicans and that
way we can get rid of all of our
terrible history we're gonna screw
everything up in the future too but and
it's gonna have perfect coherence with
our founding principles as the oldest
act of political party in the world but
no we just switched one day that if you
asked most people on the street they
would tell you that they're taught that
in schools they're taught that not
universities high schools even earlier
than that totalize don't believe the
next time they tell you that the sky is
gonna fall remember this remember those
clips remember Nancy Pelosi's crazy
frozen face and a ridiculous rhetoric
let's bring on our panel to discuss we
have the first time on the panel of
deplorable Matt Walsh is here in studio
then we have Paul Cardinal Bois and
Jacob Airy I notice gentlemen thank you
for being here welcome I notice this is
the first in studio panel we've done
during the Christmas season we have a
little mistletoe back here and it's an
all-male panel
I blame Marshall for this we almost
exclusively do all-female panels it's
the only reason I took this job and yet
it's all men today I'm very very upset
by all of this Matt welcome to the show
let's get right in you have been
critical of President
slightly critical slightly but now we've
got tax reform like 28 originalist
judges something like that Gorsuch
deregulation Isis is out of Iraq and
Syria embassy in Jerusalem Obamacare
mandate repeal mainstream media
credibility in the gutter no evidence of
collusion between Trump and Russia
plenty of evidence of collusion between
Democrats and Russia and the FBI who's
ostensibly investigating Trump and
Russia economy's soaring consumer
confidence at all-time highs
even then Shapiro is saying nice things
about Donald Trump has all of this his
first year in office changed your mind
about drama no no I never said I never
thought that it would be the end of the
world you know I'm not like Nancy Pelosi
who I love but I love Nancy Pelosi so
much she's so hilarious she's like if
she didn't exist we would have to invent
her yeah I know she's like a your great
aunt that comes to Thanksgiving and
yells at the cat or something but anyway
no III my hope with Trump was that he
would get into office and kind of let
his administration do things which i
think is what he's doing and so a lot of
the things that his administration does
have been very good and I'm happy with
them I think when it's just him
unfiltered and that's like Twitter or if
he's giving a speech or something
without a prompter that's when things go
off the rails and he undermines his own
his own agenda with his with his bad
communication skills so that's the part
that's that's good do you think because
I I once thought this and I opposed
Trump in the primary pretty vigorous
laughs for Cruz I'm beginning to think
he's the great communicator I'm
beginning to think I used to say get off
the Twitter I think the Twitter might be
the key do you think it's that he is
undermining his ledge is legislative or
his policy agenda through his rhetoric
or do you find that it's so just uncouth
it's so vulgar that it seems to
undermine nice patinas of credibility I
don't care about vulgarity and I don't
care about being harsh or anything like
that you know I've been accused of that
myself a few times so I don't care about
that my I don't see it when Trump is
feuding with Lavar ball or Arnold
Schwarzenegger or whatever he's doing or
he's complaining about CNN non-stop I
don't see how that advances the agenda
I'll tell you
I will tell you how because it's a
reality show it's because we have the
great reality show runner the one of the
kings of it for 15 years network TV
number one we have him in office and he
knows maybe I'm reading too much in but
it's certainly how it works on me he
knows that in order to keep people glued
to that Twitter to glued to him rather
than glued to CNN you have to entertain
you have to fight these cultural battles
so on the one hand you get a great I
like that he's smacking down Colin
Kaepernick I like that as a matter of
culture but I also like that he's
keeping the show engaging enough for
people that they keep tuning into that
Twitter account and it bypasses CNN in
the New York Times yeah but I don't
think there's a I say that this is
what's been happening with Trump since
the beginning I think smart
conservatives like yourself are helping
him are kind of intellectualizing what
he's doing when in reality I think he
just gets he's just a 71 year old man it
gets up in the morning it turns on Fox &
Friends and just gets mad about things
and starts shouting but he has unlike
most 71 year old man he has Twitter that
he could shout in to Twitter and so
that's I think that's all that's really
happening I don't think there's a lot of
strategy to it and I still don't see the
value okay he's got people glued they're
paying attention and they're playing
attention and then they see him
complaining about an athlete I what's
the value in that how do we now if he
was using his Twitter which he does
sometimes to call attention to actually
important issues than I would say great
but don't you think Andrew Breitbart
used to always say politics is
downstream of culture and we're in a
cultural moment right now do you not
think there's value in calling out Colin
Kaepernick or the the NFL which is
kneeling for for not just some issue but
in front of the American flag itself the
star-spangled banner itself yeah I I'm
not in favor of the kneeling thing I
think we've we've all made our opinion
known about that I don't think the idea
that had to be this year-long issue that
we're all that were outraged about for a
year I just think I don't know what I
don't know what the value is and of all
the cultural war of all the great
villains in the culture I don't think
the NFL is even in the top 100 of if I'm
going to start okay what are the sort of
organizations and institutions that we
as conservatives need to be
attacking relentlessly and I'm gonna
list a hundred I don't think the NFL
makes it on the list probably the top of
the list will be maybe something like
Planned Parenthood I would love to see
Trump maybe say a thing or two about
that he doesn't seem too concerned about
that it's been good on pro-life he
reinstated the Mexico City policy there
are arguments over how Planned
Parenthood funding is going but he's
allowed States to pull their funding at
the very least it's all pretty good well
but as it's then I don't blame him for
this entirely because it's the
Republicans in the Senate in the
Congress but the fact is that we have a
Republican House Senate and White House
and we are still giving and mills for
hundreds of millions of dollars a year
to the abortion industry which why are
people more upset about that I mean to
me that's should have been priority day
one I get in the office I'm getting rid
of that I'm doing whatever I can to get
rid of that that's a good point so those
are the to me that's what I would be
focused on but I don't mind much less
fun than football there's so much less
fun than football it's less fun it's I
know it's less fun but even though I
could I think there is a wreath we
should stand up against things like that
but for it to be the primary focus for
as long as it was I just it's too much
it's too much COFA a people are OD'ing
on Kofa fa yeah
mr. bois cardinal blah when it comes to
democrats long term lives will get back
to trump later every conversation for
the last two years obviously has to come
back to trump at some point but when it
comes to democrats long-term lies not
just tax reform killing everybody WMDs
in Iraq the JFK assassination the party
switching that sort of thing how do
Democrats convince everybody not to
trust our own lying eyes the things that
we know to be true we've seen them
ourselves I think because they raise an
entire generation an entire populace to
not think and feel only to feel only
emotion so that's why I think everything
a what from pretty much since the moment
were toddlers and we're put in front of
a television everything is geared
towards you feeling your way through
life if you feel it if you feel this if
you feel that and sometimes you feel a
little too low and then you have to
resign from the Senate
yeah and then so by creating an entire
generation that just basically lives
their intellect basically subordinates
to their emotions rather than the other
way around that's pretty much it you
don't have anything logic goes out the
window then there's not a single
argument that I've ever been in with a
leftist or somebody who's just sort of
on the fence with things I would say
even the average American really that it
the arguments that's being put forth is
based on logic or base the reason reason
or evidence based or point A to point B
I believe rock and roll music it puts
everything in their bodies and they stop
thinking Jacob the mainstream media has
changed its tune overnight on this tax
reform probably cuz we're all still here
and we're not dead is this blithe
ignorance or is it cynicism when the
media report falsehood it's like it's
going to kill everybody it's gonna raise
everybody's taxes are they lying or they
just weak and ignorant I think they are
lying I I think it's an intentional
falsehood that the mainstream media puts
out all the time it's like we were
talking about how when Ted Kennedy died
they didn't mention the fact that he
committed manslaughter right in fact
someone said oh the girl he left to die
helplessly she would have voted for him
if she was alive that's right they put
that stuff out there and the sad thing
is Republicans repeat it when Mitt
Romney ran against Ted Kennedy who by
the way he almost he almost beat Ted
Kennedy Romney didn't say Oh Ted Kennedy
committed manslaughter that should have
been enough to win the election but Mitt
Romney just went along with these
mainstream media lies oh no Ted Kennedy
he's such a lion in the silence oh my
gosh that poor girl alive yeah exactly
and I think it is an intentional
falsehood and the sad thing is the
American people don't hold them
accountable when they have egg on their
face yeah whatever reason yeah that is
true
it's not not enough cough ever see the
it's a balancing act you can't have too
much against if you get too much you're
gonna overdose on it
now speaking of overdosing on we have
much more to talk about we have nikki
Haley and Donald Trump smacking around
the UM that's a glorious we're going to
talk about a Cardinal law former
Archbishop of Boston who was at the
center of the Catholic abuse scandal
we're gonna be talking about that with
her
three quarters Catholic panel because he
just died today and we're gonna be
talking about the mother who is two
months older than her daughter and we're
going to be talking about the war on
Christmas and I'm gonna try to enlist
Matt Walsh into Santa's army but you
can't see any of that unless you go to
daily whiter calm right now we
appreciate all of the people who already
subscribe you help keep the lights on Co
FFA and mic up if you don't it's it's
Christmas time go over there treat
yourself
treat yourself in a family member it's
only ten dollars a month or $100 for an
annual membership what do you get well
you get me you get the end or Clavin
sure you get the Ben Shapiro show you
get no ads on the website bla bla bla
you get this Rosie O'Donnell alone could
cause Armageddon like tidal waves all
over the earth with her salty salty
leftist ears protect yourself and your
family now is the time I know it's so
easy to think of it maybe we forget
about these things but you have to
remember protect yourself and your
family get the leftist here's tumblr it
could save your life someday go to daily
whiter calm we'll be right back
UN Ambassador nikki Haley and President
Trump are smacking them around today she
tweeted at the UN we're always asked to
do more and give more so when we make a
decision at the will of the American
people about where to locate our embassy
in Jerusalem we don't expect those we've
helped to target us on Thursday there
will be a vote criticizing our choice
the US will be taking names duh then
Donald Trump followed this up President
Trump said for all of these nations that
take our money and then they vote
against us at the Security Council or
they vote against us potentially at the
Assembly they take hundreds of millions
of dollars even billions of dollars then
they vote against as well we're watching
those votes let them vote against as
we're gonna save a lot we don't care but
this isn't like it used to be where they
could vote against you and then you pay
them hundreds of millions of dollars and
nobody knows what they're doing you know
Jacob that sounds like a threat to me is
this threat serious will Trump pull
foreign aid or is he bluffing from what
I've seen I don't think it's a bluff I
think he's serious if he wants to do it
anyway he's been talking about it for
years
exactly and quite frankly I want him to
do this so I actually hope they do vote
against this by the way why are we
paying all these nations money we never
get anything returned we bailed them out
of every World War I say you know they
can pay their own way for a change let
them find their armies with all their
socialist taxes you know I I say go for
it and good on nikki Haley she's
probably the greatest human ambassador
we've ever had excuse me there was John
Bolton I don't want anything that
excludes my man John Bolton second best
now Matt there I think there is a
legitimate argument for foreign aid some
say that by having foreign aid we're
able to exert greater influence over
these countries greater influence in the
world some say we look like a bunch of
wusses and we're just paying the people
and saying thank you ma'am may I have
another and they smack us more and put
their cigarettes out on our chest which
is should we cut u.s. foreign aid to
these people I'm gonna go with the
latter I think it's a it's a it's
immoral it's a scandal to take money
because of course we know liberals don't
understand this but we understand that
the government isn't just the month
they're not the money isn't falling from
the sky they're taking the money from
the
can people so the idea that there take
that the government is taking money from
my family and giving it to a foreign
government I think is just is scandalous
and I know what's been going on for a
long time so I'm you know and I think
Trump is more on that side of the fence
and I agree with them and this is one
thing this is where now usually I'm
opposed to how Trump communicates
because I think it distracts now this is
something this is the kind of thing that
no other Republican would ever say right
it's the right thing to say and if he
actually does it which I hope he does
then uh then I will gladly say that this
is something that no other Republican
would have done and it's a good thing
and it's exactly the kind of thing that
if we can get Trump doing this sort of
thing then I think people who supported
Trump can make the argument that in the
end it was the right thing to support
him over the other the other 17
candidates because it's the sort of move
that no other Republican would pull and
he does get better too one notices like
during the campaign his rhetoric was in
many places quite objectionable and it's
gotten less objectionable he's getting
more of these good things so if it keeps
keeps on getting better and better I
would be very pleased with I would be my
skepticism will have vanished basically
mr. bois what do you think there is no
role for leadership by funding these
countries and being able to dangle it
over their heads will America be
stronger and have a stronger hand in the
world if we pull back I certainly think
it will make these nations that are
receiving aid from us think second best
before they spit in our face I mean I
think they're just sort of they're
getting a lot of kickbacks from us
they're ungrateful and they need to stop
biting the hand that feeds them that's
good we're all talking like mobsters now
okay let's move on Bernard Cardinal law
the former Archbishop of Boston whom the
Boston Globe exposed to have covered up
sexual abuse by priests has died we are
three-quarters Catholic today and we're
working on Jacob maybe by the end of the
show it'll be a hundred percent Paul you
were accordingly yourself obviously your
eminence how is the church recovered
from the sex abuse scandal now 15 years
later I would have to say in
colonel e they're doing a better job
certainly trying to clean out the
seminaries and inputs solid protections
that were in place prior to the 1950s
that led to this there's certainly a lot
of liturgical abuses going on a lot of
liberalism going on in the church and
frankly that is what this stemmed from
the leftists want to go ahead and say
that was you know the Catholic culture
and celibacy that's nonsense if the
priests throughout history was having
difficulty with his celibacy they would
find him with a prostitute or with a
married woman or someone else and
perished some of those Pope's like the
Borgia Pope swear I mean they had a ton
of illegitimate Julia so so so so that's
that's a bunch of fraudulent and
nonsense in terms of the public image I
don't think it's gotten much better and
that's largely because Catholic media is
just is horrible
right now and the Catholic message is
horrible right now in the culture so and
Hollywood just created spotlight and of
course they're never gonna tell the
truth about you know what really was
taking place so it's a mixed bag I think
it's gonna take a longer time to fully
recover it I do think that what's
happening in Hollywood right now with
the me2 movement and the sex scandals is
sort of shifting the pendulum I think
the Catholic Church they went through
their beading if you will and now we're
kind of turning the spotlight on leftist
culture and their madness and this is
this is the this is the moment for
Catholics and media to take the mantle
and and turn it back on them and really
take it home and just say like you know
what we have the right answer and just
take it away from what I'm just pleased
that you're blaming the sex abuse
scandal on bad liturgy those acoustic
guitars drive me so crazy I'm very
pleased by that Matt many people have
been hoping for and predicting the end
of Christianity of the Catholic Church
since approximately I think the Year
Zero so Caiaphas couldn't make it happen
the Muslim armies at battle tours
couldn't make it happen the Muslim
armies at the Battle of Lepanto couldn't
make it happen not Nietzsche not Richard
Dawkins not anybody else how
history judge the significance of the
sex abuse scandal I think it's
impossible that Martin Luther
by the way also is another one that
could make it I know I was gonna hold my
tongue but I you're absolutely right he
didn't make it happen
Oh sad for him I would it's impossible
to understate how the significance of it
I mean this is Satan made great inroads
into the church itself with the scandal
obviously because that's what it is it's
satanic when you look at what some of
these priests were doing and guys like
Cardinal law it's but it's also
difficult kind of like what Paul is
talking about it's difficult for
Catholics because we know how horrible
it is and we don't want to understate it
and we need to talk about that but what
we've been saying for the past 15 years
all these people that are that are
acting so shocked by the church they
have their own issues in their own
institutions and nobody's nobody's
talking about that and in fact even and
you know it's if you look at their been
studies done that in the Protestant
church the sex abuse sex abuse is an
even bigger problem than it ever was in
the Catholic Church in public schools I
mean it's it's just I have to do what
the status but one in every I want to
say won't ever you well I won't say that
I want to misquote but thousands and
thousands of kids have put it that way
are being abused I see those stories of
the cute blonde teacher and the little
fifteen-year-old boy they're out every
day yeah all the time it really is every
day more than more than every day so
there always is this difficult game to
play where you it's not a game but it's
this difficult move where you want to
also shed the light on this greater
problem that's happening in the culture
across the board without trying to do
the what about them
for what about what about you guys you
lefties what about you look at yourself
mm-hmm
Jacob you're not yet home in the church
universal not yet maybe by the end of
the show did the scandal change outside
perspectives of the Catholic Church or
was it just a mo for people who were
already critical of it I think it was a
mo and I actually believe in her I
actually agree with with Paul and Matt I
don't think it was it was a problem
within the Catholic Church itself I
personally and I know I know I'm
probably even going to take flak from
some of my fellow Protestants but I
believe as long as you believe in Jesus
Christ as your Savior you go to heaven
and so I
see it as a as a issue within the
Catholic Church
other than Cardinal law should have been
defrocked I think that was a bad move to
make to move him to Rome because I that
made it look like the Catholic Church
was covering someone after him and so I
think it was more about optics
when it came from other Christians
looking in outside Christians looking in
it was kind of like oh man I was a bad
move because and you know and
evangelicals aren't immune to this I
mean Baker and that guy in Louisiana and
you know all we we have had our own
share of scandals just like matt said
and so and I know evangelicals came out
and other Protestants came out and that
was wrong there should have never been
any finger-pointing that being said
though we those priests did disgusting
horrible things and Cardinal law all did
the wrong thing
no man if you want to say oh the
spotlight was misleading or this media
report was misleading and teachers
abused kids more Cardinal law was
actively involved in covering up the
scandal and he should have been removed
from his position and that that's and
that is my honest take on it it was
something that was horrible but I think
that like Paul said I do think the
Catholic Church has may move
particularly thanks to Pope Benedict he
he really took a hand in in combating
and putting in decent safety ministry
hey Pope Benedict was still the Pope you
might have a shot at a lot of
conservative Protestants yeah I got a
loved Pope Benedict excellent book for
Advent as the infancy narrative is
really nice we have to move on we're
talking about weird sex we got to move
on to some weirder sex a mother in
Tennessee is only two months older than
her daughter which means that I know
Tennesseans are very precocious
I mean pregnancy has gotten very out of
hand the mother twenty six-year-old Emma
Trent Gibson has broken a world record
by giving birth to a baby whose embryo
was frozen in 1992 we are really through
the looking-glass now are we not Matt
how should people who were concerned
with natural law who have bioethical
thoughts how should they consider this
event
I don't know that's why we bring you on
well you know declarations there's
there's two questions here there's the
question of IVF and creating embryos and
creating human beings in a petri dish
which is immoral and wrong and bad and
this is just it's a it's a it's a simple
case of just because science can do it
doesn't mean it should right just
because it can solve a problem which is
infertility doesn't mean we should go
that direction and be making dinosaurs
we submit Dinah says we should be making
people we should be making any any
living thing a picture that's probably I
guess at least dinosaur some people so
there's that question and then you end
up with and now we have like we were
talking before the show 600,000 to a
million human embryos in storage so
they're just frozen little embryos yeah
they're yeah we store them like you know
hot pockets in the freezer but these are
these are human beings and so the first
question is well it's wrong to do that
the second question is now that they're
there because of this immoral act what
do we do with them and that's the I
don't know part because normally and I
know the Church teaches and I think this
is just consist of natural law that to
go and you know pull pull a human being
out of storage and implant them in your
body is unnatural and wrong however they
are there so the other organs they have
to let them die so I would think I don't
know but I would think the morally
correct answer here is it's a matter of
kind of intent mmm-hmm so if your
intention is to do an act of mercy and
to rescue a human being from this limbo
state bye-bye that's what it is it's
earthly limbo right and if your if your
attention is act of mercy rescued a
human being from limbo bring him into
you know the world then I think it's
right if your intention is I have a
problem I need to solve I'm infertile
and oh we've got these embryos I sure
would like a kid today right then it's
wrong so I that's what I would think the
answer is I don't know
Paul Cardinal wha you are an eminent
Cardinal there are there are lots of
these little frozen embryos so should
there be a movement now to save them
from earthly limbo like Matt is saying
should there be a movement to go and
rescue these little frozen pre babies
or is that taking pro-life too far yeah
it's a very new issue there's actually
been two paragraphs written about it in
an encyclical in 2008 by Pope Benedict
Dignity talked as personae
so essentially what and Matt talked
about it is the problem here is yes its
intent and the proper way to frame it is
embryonic or embryo adoption so
basically like you said the idea of
family or saying I'm going to go out and
I'm going to save one little yeah one of
these embryos not I need to start a
family not you know I you know I want to
start building my family look at how I
build my family because with regular IVF
very often there will be multiple
embryos that are created and then
they'll implant them and it's very
expensive it's very hard to see which
one will implant and then they'll abort
some of the others so there's this
abortion component for regular IVF that
you don't have with embryonic adoption
yeah so the goal really is to stop this
from happening stop the IVF that's gonna
be very hard in this culture stop the
freezing of these embryos creating of
these and then the freezing and the
storing of them and then what you're
doing that these poor souls that are
stuck in earthly limbo get them a chance
try and get them a chance to be adopted
without turning it into this trendy
thing of like oh yeah that's like the
new pit bull you know pit bulls were
really cool for a while to it yeah so
the new ones embryo spiritually I'm
thinking to myself I mean that's
something because every child at the
moment of conception has a soul these I
mean if theoretically these are all
souls that are not able to die or depart
from their bodies and fur could happen
for I don't sounds like it's it's it's
insane Jacob as we move into our brave
new world
what should conservatives think about
IVF in general in vitro fertilization a
ton of downsides there these abortions
that are part of it
it's very clinical it misses the most
fun part of creating a baby which is
probably usually left out of the
discussion on the other hand it is now
common practice
it allows infertile couples to have
children
how should conservatives approach the
issue moving forward I think it all goes
down to intent and it puts pro lifers in
an awkward situation I am of the belief
that anything created by science doesn't
have a soul I believe that only through
natural conception does one have a soul
wait what about the little what about
people who were born IVF they don't have
souls well no that's their little I know
it puts me in the flesh that's private
well I just think that I'm just gonna
say I don't think clones have souls I
don't I think they're they're just
organic robots and that's my humble
opinion but it also but also I think
that they have a but but now that this
is a part of what we are it's we're
gonna have to take a serious look at it
I honestly don't know where the sleeves
conservatives are we going to move
forward and and get these people out and
give them an opportunity to live because
one of the biggest rights in America is
you have the right to life you have that
right and I don't think freezing them
whether you think they have souls or not
freezing them because if they do
freezing them is is wrong you shouldn't
just store them so I think I think this
paints us in a little bit of a corner
you know I got to tell you pal I'm glad
that I'm not your clump I'm really glad
some really blown a phobic language that
you're using on here outrageous okay
let's get off of these questions of
natural law and souls and everything get
on to the real battle the war on
Christmas here is a glimpse right now
from the battlefield just outside our
window oh no they got him they got him
they got Santa Santa down I got to put
on my helmet for this this is it still
lit up yeah it is okay alright ready to
go I don't have my candy cane pipe
anymore Matt I read it I usually I love
your writing I love reading your pieces
you wrote a piece a couple days ago that
I almost threw my computer at the window
I was so horrified I wanted to bring you
up on charges marshal charges for
evacuating your post in the war on
Christmas you don't think it's a real
thing
you don't think conservatives should be
worried about it no not at all I think
it's
if you think it's ridiculous I well that
is not me that's not that's practically
yeah my Christmas tree bowtie I I think
it's even dumber than the standing than
the NFL think I'll be honest with you I
there there there are two aspects to it
the the question is is it is it an
important issue like is it something we
should worry about and the other
question is should we even is it even is
it helping Christmas in other words when
we try to essentially force people to
say Merry Christmas and to decorate
their department stores with with
mistletoes and plastic reindeer and
everything and so on that second I think
I moved right to that second question I
would say that it's it's I don't think
that we we helped Christmas in other
words if you have what would we consider
it an act of war on Christmas if like
for instance if Macy's were to say we're
banning Christmas decorations you're not
allowed to say Merry Christmas right
then that's that's the war on Christmas
isn't it's the latter though because it
they still have the decorations the
decorations are up everywhere it's not
like we forced them to people put them
up because if they put them up earlier
and earlier actually because they want
to get people to buy more presents and
these sort of things the the act of the
war on Christmas and why I think it's so
insidious is it's all about language
it's just a front in this politically
correct
euphemistic battle so what they do is
they have all the the reindeer even they
have the little Christmas snowflakes or
whatever but they won't they won't call
it Christmas they'll say it's for the
holidays they use this euphemism
holidays even though there's only one
major holiday in December so how let me
ask you how is the sacredness of
Christmas preserved by having the
cashier at JC Penney just have this
wrote greeting of Merry Christmas as
opposed to saying happy holidays which
by the way as you know holidays means
holy day so they're still acknowledging
but they say holidays but if there's
only one there's only one major holiday
in December what's the other holiday
Hanukkah is a relatively minor Jewish
holiday compared to other Jewish
holidays it only became a big necklace
the summer for example this is actually
another point on this so you do make a
great point obviously Christmases
commercial
a lot of people there the Christmas and
Easter Christians they go to church
twice a year maybe usually once a year
and they don't go any other day and
that's a problem I totally grant that
that's a problem but isn't hypocrisy the
tribute that vais pays to virtue is it
is that situation really made better by
indulging this bizarre campaign to
replace Christmas the obviously the
central holiday at Christmastime with
this weird euphemism holidays where we
pretend that Hanukkah is a major holiday
even within the Jewish religion and the
Kwanzaa is anything but a socialist
contrivance it seems to me you know
Santa we have Santa Claus up what does
Santa Claus have to do with the birth
birth of Christ not terribly much except
that this folk tradition that we have
the merging of the Christianity with
these various folk traditions does speak
a little bit to it we have Saint
Nicholas so we have st. Nicholas is
known for two things giving out presents
to people and punching heretics in the
face and we incorporate the former into
our Christmas traditions that doesn't
seem like such a bad thing to me yeah I
would love to incorporate the latter to
it right I mean if I started doing that
at Macy's but I I guess the here's the
way I look at it if a department store a
company or whatever says don't say Merry
Christmas a Happy Holidays their logic
partly is well we can't really wish
because Christmas means Christ Mass as
you know it's it's a very religious
phrase and it's it's it's intensely
religious so the the logic of these
corporations is well if we say that then
we're essentially endorsing that
religion we're promoting it and and so
they say well we're a secular company
we're not interested in promoting a
religion so we're just gonna back off
and not and not say anything or just use
this generalized phrase and my point is
in that decision they're actually
showing more respect even if
unintentionally but they're showing more
respect for the religious nature of
Christmas then are a lot of Christians
who only care about Christianity when
it's Christmas time but then shouldn't
they not use the word holy day shouldn't
they not use the phrase holidays that
they're saying we don't want to take a
religious stand because I think they're
not you
for that reason I think they're not
doing it because there's a left-wing
euphemistic struggle that infects all of
our politically correct language
Christmas is just one little aspect of
that but by that logic if there is only
one major holiday that is celebrated in
December shouldn't they just not
acknowledge anything if they're going to
acknowledge that there is something
there is a holiday that must not be
named because we're respecting the
religious nature of of this country and
of the people who celebrate Christmas
then they should take down the ornaments
right they should take down the
snowflakes and the trees and reindeer so
my so my I guess I would I guess my
problem with the war on Christmas is
that they're not going far enough
take take the tech to take it all down I
don't it's because I don't need this
this this the way that Christmas is so
ubiquitous it's only drained and of its
significance I think it will be great we
live in a part of the point I'm in that
piece we live in a godless satanic
culture we should have to face that fact
even around Christmas I know we want to
run from that and we want to pretend
we're driving down the street we see the
Christmas lights everywhere we say well
look at all these Christians are so
great and meanwhile you know the people
the Christmas lights are in their house
you know they're looking at porn there
whatever beating their kids whatever
they're doing what you want to do you
want to take down the reindeer and you
want to replace them with little devils
and little like Baphomet it's I think it
would be good if we got to a point in
our culture where only the people who
are authentically really devoutly
observantly Christian even acknowledge
or celebrate Christmas because they're
the only ones who should be there's only
ones it it's it's this is not a holiday
for everyone to enjoy the spirit of
Christmas is giving to people it's not
what it is we're celebrating the birth
of Christ because he came to this earth
to redeem mankind that's why we're
celebrating him and so it's the people
who actually care about Christianity who
have a right to our celebration I don't
like how our culture comes in and takes
all of the Christmas all the Christian
celebrations and gets rid of all the
religious significance and they just
keep that they keep the celebrations for
themselves to do with Mardi Gras they do
it sort of with you know they do I
certainly do it Mardi Gras they do with
st. Patrick's Day it's you know these
are ours we we earned those holidays in
a sense culturally appropriating from us
they already did away on this point
though the Incarnation does draw all of
the nations in
into Christ even though you know we see
those three wise men come from the land
of the sunrise
they weren't Jews they lived at a time
when there was there were prophecies
floating around that the ruler of the
world would come from Judah but even in
that incarnate in them the first year of
incarnation you see a journey of the
world who might be kind of kooky and
their religious views are a little out
there or not quite there might be Magi
from which we get Magician but they were
drawn a little closer to Christ it
seemed I'm looking at it a little more
glass-half-full if we can get them to
like Santa Claus
this happened to Andrew Clavin he really
liked Christmas as a boy even though he
came from a basically secular Jewish
household and years later that played
some role in his conversion to Christ in
a mite in a way that didn't involve
Christmas cookies and you know little
decorations on the tree because I think
in where I disagree with you Matt is
what you're talking about is a society
that completely totally takes away their
decorations and it's gone and it's
everything that's not a society that
takes away their decorations and we're
gonna let the Christians do their thing
that's a society like the Soviet Union
they don't just take the decorations
down they ensure that nobody puts any
decorations up so we're in a post
Christian society right now but we are
not yet fully in an anti Christian
society yet and so long as that shell of
a Christian society remains we have to
protect that shell so we can fill it up
with something Christian because that
natural law of being around the beauty
of the decorations of Christmas and
hearing people say Merry Christmas and
Santa Claus like he said about Andrew
Clavin could play a role in somebody's
conversion later on I know how to do it
I know how to make all of this work and
to unite all of these various armies
some who want more Santa Claus and some
who want the war to go further and you
know have the devil's go up we can we
have to add this important component of
punching heretics to our Christmas
traditions yeah st. Nicholas as Santa
Claus himself would have wanted follow
la la la la la la la that is our show
today thank you for being here Matt
Walsh great to have you I you got to
come back next time you're in town Jacob
berry
Paul Corton habla I'm Michael
this is the my granola show get your
mailbag questions in you have is the
last one before Christmas who knows when
the comet and the meteor is gonna strike
earth because of tax reforms so make
sure you get them in your eternal soul
might depend on it see them see you soon
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Marshall Benson executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey supervising producer
Mathis Glover our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex's and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Knoll show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2017